今回のセクションでは TypeScriptとVue.jsを一緒に使う方法について見ていきます
TypeScriptってのは JavaScriptに静的に型をチェックする機能を追加した言語になります
なので例えば TypeScriptを使うことで
本来文字列が入るべきところに数字が入ってますよみたいな
一般的なエラーを静的につまり実行する前に
事前にコードから知ることができるようになります
また逆にこういう型を使っているなら
こんなプロパティが使えますよみたいな
自動補完をVS Codeとかと併用すれば使用できるようになります
なのでTypeScriptは結構便利なんですね
Vue.jsはそのTypeScriptと一緒に使うことができますので
その方法について今回紹介します
じゃあどうやったらいいのかというと
結論から言うとまず最初のCreateViewをした時に
TypeScriptを使いますかという選択肢が出てくるんですね
そこでイエスを選択する必要があります
なのでちょっと実際に見てみますね
例えばNPMCreateViewAtLatestとしますね
そうするとプロジェクトの名前は何でもいいので
今回はViewTypeScriptLessonとかにしておきます
ここでAddTypeScriptと聞かれます
なのでここをイエスにしてください
それ以外はノーにしますね
このイエスリントとプリティアだけはイエスにしておきたいと思います
でこの新しく出来上がるフォルダを
VS Codeで開きますね
そうするとこんなページになります
このオープンフォルダとかで開いてください
でせっかくなので
このイエスリントの設定の
View3エッセンシャルのところを
レコメンディットと押して
ちょっと厳しいルールにしておきたいと思います
でこんな風にCreateViewはTypeScript専用の設定ファイルだったり
必要なパッケージやコマンドを用意してくれているのが分かると思います
なのでそのままNPMインストールすると
TypeScriptを使う準備が完了するんですね
でTypeScriptの拡張子は.jsじゃなくて.tsなので
このソースフォルダのmain.jsもmain.tsになります
とはいえ基本的にTypeScriptはほとんどJavaScriptと同じなので
特に書き方は大きく変わりません
ただし型のチェックを事前に行ってくれますので
例えばマウントに数字とかを入れると
こんな風に赤い波線でエラーを出してくれたりします
これ厳密にはVisual Studio Code自体が
TypeScriptの型のチェックをする機能をデフォルトで内蔵していまして
そのVisual Studio Codeの機能によってこんな風に
ES-Lintみたいなエラーを出してくれています
なのでTypeScriptを使うときはVisual Studio Code VS Codeと一緒に使うことが
非常におすすめですし
一緒に使うことでこんな風にすぐにエラーに気づくことができるわけです
もしこれVisual Studio Codeに頼るのではなくて
自分で型のチェックを行いたい場合は
このPackage.jsonのスクリプトにある
このTypeCheckコマンドを使用すれば
型のチェックを行うことができます
なのでコマンドでNPM run TypeCheckとすると
こんな風にエラーが出ます
ただ基本的にはVisual Studio Codeはすぐに
こんな風にエラーを出してくれますので
このコマンドを毎回使う必要はありません
ちょっと元に戻しておきますね
その上でViewのコンポーネント上で
TypeScriptを使う方法についてみたいと思います
まず一度このアセットフォルダを消しますね
なのでこのmain.tsのCSSのインポート分も消します
コンポーネントフォルダの中も一度全て消しますね
アップロッドビューの方も1から書きますね
スクリプトセットアップとテンプレートを用意します
テンプレートの中はH1タグで
適当にTypeScriptとかと書いておきますね
NPM.debで開発用のサーバーも立ち上げたいと思います
ブラウザをこんな風に横に置いて
このURLにアクセスしました
なのでTypeScriptと出ています
ちょっとズームしますね
じゃあこのViewのシングルファイルコンポーネントの中で
TypeScriptを使うにはどうしたらいいのかというと
このスクリプトタグのところに
HTMLの属性みたいな感じで
rangイコールTS
つまりTypeScriptの意味ですね
と書くんですね
こうするともうTypeScriptを
このコンポーネントの中で使えるようになります
なので例えばですけれども
TypeScriptで関数を書くときは
ちょっとaddという関数を用意したいんですけれども
TypeScriptでは引数にコロンをつけて
型を指定することができるんですね
こういう書き方がもうできるようになっていますし
テンプレートの方でも型のチェックが行われるようになるので
例えばちょっとボタンタグを用意して
それがクリックされたら
このaddの関数を実行するとしますね
このときに普通に数字を入れれば問題ないんですけれども
もしここに例えば文字列を入れてしまった場合は
こんな風にすぐに赤い波線のエラーが出るようになります
なのでちゃんとTypeScriptのチェックが行われているわけですね
こんな風にいろんな設定をした上で
コンポーネントのスクリプトのところに
rang="ts",と書くことで
TypeScriptをVue.jsのコンポーネントで使うことができます
さあでは次からはVue.jsのそれぞれの機能
例えばrefとかpropsとか
そういうものに対して
TypeScriptをどう使うのかを
ざっと一気に紹介していきたいと思います
これをざっと一気に紹介していきたいと思います